The ‘needy’ person is
a stock figure of caricature:
they call too much, they cry when
you leave to get a glass of water,
they feel put out when
you check your phone,
they were upset when
you watched a film without them.
We hate needy people a lot.
But let’s look at this another way.
There are, of course, a few
pathologically dependent people at large,
but a lot of the time,
far more than is generally accepted,
the person who has the problem
isn’t the ‘needy’ person at all, it is us;
the ones who are doing the accusing.
We will feel someone is sickeningly ‘needy’
when we don’t see ourselves as
appropriate targets of someone else’s need.
Somewhere inside,
we don’t trust that we are reliable,
strong, dependable, admirable or decent;
we aren’t quite grown-up,
and those who need something from us
therefore come across as
deranged and fitting targets for mockery.
At the first sign that someone is
becoming reliant on us, we flinch.
We suspect that someone who needs us enough
to depend on us
for a pleasant weekend or
evening must be diseased.
At the root of our hatred of
so-called needy people is self-hatred.
Ostensibly, we all want love,
but when love actually starts
to be reciprocated,
it may prove intensely alarming if
we are not convinced of our own lovability.
We can start to think very badly of the
person we liked only a little time before.
We feel they are naive
in finding us wonderful,
a great deal more wonderful
than we feel we are.
We think them gullible,
and too easily taken in by a character
we ourselves don’t believe in.
The solution isn’t necessarily
to try to change a lover,
by telling them to stop asking so much.
They most probably aren’t
asking too much at all.
They just aren’t afflicted with
a sense that it is peculiar
to be loved or to love.
Put another way, they’re just
strong enough to reveal
that they aren’t invulnerable and
judicious enough to like the look of us.
They rightly presume showing need
is a precondition of strength
rather than weakness.
The solution is to revise
our view of ourselves;
to see ourselves as
more or less plausible people
for someone else to stand in need of.
The fear of ‘needy’ people is
only a species of self-hatred
rippling outwards to tar our lover.
A reduction of self-hatred doesn’t
depend on self-boosterism
(telling ourselves how great we are).
We should learn to tolerate ourselves
not by believing that we are wonderful,
but via a secure realisation that everyone
is both OK and sometimes a bit awful:
that is enough to deserve love.
We can be cured of our uncommonly
vicious self-suspicion
by a more accurate vision of
what constitutes normality.
Of course we are a bit a weak, a bit sly
and a bit foolish, to put it gently.
But so is everyone.
We’re no more idiotic or
wayward than the next person.
We can embrace a person’s hopes for
a close and deep relationship with us
simply on the basis that we are,
in fact, all a bit odd and broken.
The need that the lover
has of us isn’t delusional,
it’s an accurate request that any
flawed human might make of another
comparably damaged example.
We’ll start to find other people
a lot less needy,
that is, a lot less alarming
when they need us,
when we can accept with good grace
that there is nothing unusually
strange or abhorrent
about someone deciding they like us.